hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten mit heute packen wir leckeren
hähnchen und samira wünscht sich
eigentlich nichts aber den haben wir
schon als video gemacht und die nuss
hans den eignet sich ganz gut für die
winterzeit weil sie mit nuss und zimt
gemacht werden aber die kann man das
ganze jahr über essen und man kann sich
super vorbereiten und zwar brauchen wir
für den teig nur ganz wenige zutaten und
die stelle ich euch jetzt mal kurz vor
wir brauchen 300 gramm mehl 200 gramm
butter dies ganz kalt und 200 gramm
frischkäse da nimm dir bitte einen
doppel rahmen frischkäse also keine
light version
das waren schon die zutaten für den teig
und es sind die zutaten für die füllung
und zwar brauchen wir 100 gramm zucker
100 gramm braunen zucker dass sie dann
etwas hübscher aus 50 gramm gehackte
mandeln 100 gramm gemahlene mandeln und
für das schöne aroma noch ein bisschen
abrieb von orangenschale ein bisschen
zimt und wer es gern schokolade mag kann
sogar noch etwas nutella benutzen
ihr habt gesehen die zutaten für den
teig nur drei stück und da kommt auch
kein zucker rhein bei nämlich der zucker
dann schon im belag steckt und der teig
ist dann eher neutralen und die füllung
und die dass der belag macht es dann
schön lecker
danke und die zutaten werden muss kurz
in der küchenmaschine zusammenmixen
zudem knetet ihr könnt es natürlich auch
per hand machen aber dann wird der teig
sehr weich und ich würde euch da einfach
harten im mixer zu nehmen jetzt nehmen
wir das mehl und das kommt jetzt in die
rührschüssel rasch ein ganz tolles herz
gemalt aber kannst du auch herunter
einfach ein
das macht nichts dann die buddy habe ich
in kleine stücke geschnitten damit
einfach schneller vermixt wird und noch
der frischkäse
da kommt auch frischkäse aufgehen
und jetzt kommt das ganze einfach auf
den nächsten teil der decke und jetzt
abschalten
einfach bietet sich verbunden hat und
jetzt gehen wir den teig auf eine
silikon matte mit etwas nähen vor sich
zehn meter und jetzt formen wird daraus
ganz schnell eine kugel und müssen dann
den teig kalt stellen weil er jetzt
nämlich sehr klebrig ist und wenn ihr
merkt dass er zu weich ist gibt einfach
noch ein bisschen mehr dazu
und dann nehmt ihr einfach den teig und
gebt ihnen der schüssel rein und so muss
er erstmal gekühlt werden für mindestens
zwei stunden
aber ich will zu machen dass ich einfach
einen abend vorher macht und dann könnte
einfach am nächsten tag durchstarten und
jetzt nehmen wir die zutaten für den
belag also die nüsse das darfst du
machen entschuldigung habe ich nicht
dran gedacht und vermischen das jetzt
einfach alles zusammen
ja du hast doch viel toller als ich
super und es ab und da gebe ich jetzt
noch ein bisschen orangenschalen abrieb
ihr könnt aber auch andere aromen ist
ohne wird aufpassen bei orange finde ich
ja von dem auch wenn ihr mit ungefähr
einen halben teelöffel zimt computer und
du darfst das jetzt verrühren okay und
ich hol schon mal den teig raus das ist
richtig schön kalt und den gebe ich
jetzt hier drauf und jetzt verteilen wir
den teig in vier portionen
die drei teile stellen wird erstmal noch
weg und einen teil vor mich jetzt ganz
schnell zu einer kugel zusammen
ja und ich arbeite hier auf der silicon
matte und geht jetzt von meiner nuss
zucker mischung hier drauf und wird den
teig darauf ausrollen
das darfst du gleich nochmal machen so
erstmal drin wänden bisschen rund formen
und jetzt hole ich das auf etwa 26 cm
durchmesser aus deswegen habe ich da auf
die matte darunter weil ich da die
kreise schon vorgezeichnet habe und sehe
ganz genau wann ich eben die größe
erreicht hat und dann einfach mal mit
den fingern wieder zurecht formen
jetzt nämlich sondern portionierer und
1016 stücke er könnte es aber auch ganz
gut einfach mit einem messer vierteln
und in 16 stücke teilen aber so haben
wir so schön gleichmäßig okay jetzt muss
man das einfach nur noch hier abtrennen
und jetzt ist ja auch wie sowie hier
keinen zucker im teig haben weil nämlich
aus dem raum mit ganz viel zucker ist
und jetzt gerade jetzt wird es einfach
so eingerollt zu kleinen hörnchen und
die lege ich dann mit der spitze nach
unten damit ziemlich wieder aufgehen
ja auch ein backblech du kannst es
richtig gut machen bisschen enger wohl
ein bisschen enger angehen
auf sich sein
und jetzt haben wir das erste blech
schon fertig da passt gut die hälfte des
teiges drauf und so werden die nuss
hörnchen jetzt bei 180 grad für zwölf
bis sechzehn minuten gebacken
es kann auch länger dauern weil sie
sollen schön knusprig werden und
goldbraun werden und der zuckerwert ecm
obendrauf ein bisschen karamellisieren
und wer möchte kann jetzt noch welche
mit nutella füllung machen und die
zeigen wir euch aufwärtskurs
unsere nutzer sind sind jetzt fertig und
her duft auch schon richtig gut und hier
sieht man zum beispiel dass hier der
zucker schon karamellisiert ist im
einzel dranhängen nächste schlag denn
einfach dran weil ich mal ganz gern und
wir richten das jetzt hier auf seine
tasche an und möchte während dem backen
die idee gekommen dass man das ganze ja
auch mal pikant füllen könnte und da
würde ich das mal in einem anderen video
zeigen da habe ich schon ganz viele
ideen für eine pikante füllung und man
kann sie auch süß mit allem anderen
fühlen man kann ja mal lade drauf
streichen oder etwas apfelmus aber
sobald man eben was drauf streicht wird
es ein bisschen klebriger uns wird etwas
schwerer zu wollen aber es geht trotzdem
sehr gut und ich würde sagen sanierer
kopf wieder
dann probieren wir mal 1 und sie sind
richtig schön lecker außen rum sind
etwas knusprig und innen drin noch schön
weich und ich finde gerade das
orangenaroma in den muscheln recht ich
gut man kann sie super vorbereiten ihr
könnt auch den teig nehmen und die
hörnchen auf rollen und den teig
einfrieren und wenn ihr dann gestern
habt einfach furzen backofen schieben
da sind keine grenzen gesetzt das rezept
gibt es dann zum nachlesen auf sallys -
blog.de und die pikante variante die
herzhafte variante die kommt dann auch
noch vielleicht habt ihr da auch schon
ideen und könnt ihr einfach unten in die
kommentare reinschreiben
ich freue mich schon aufs nächste rezept
und wissen einfach das nächste mal
wieder bis bald